and on the mound pablo lopez opening day
i'm sorry
his opening start of the year friday
against the rays five innings of two hit
shutout ball he walked two struck out
four and the home opener for the mets so
some
pregame festivities i'm sure grounded to
first aguilar goes to jazz back
over to first the old three six three
double play
goldschmidt could not have hit that more
perfectly to aguilar
at first base the two seamer going the
other way jams of just a little bit
one hopper quick pivot and an easy
double play
clearly everything okay for nolan in
2021 one
third baseman two the other in the
opener the cardinals jumped out to a six
nothing lead with flaherty on the mound
and he lasted just four and a third
94 pitches on a cold day it was 37
degrees
and a pick off here carpenter to arnotto
the tag applied and the outs
short arms it a little bit fly ball
lifted into
right field backing up tommy edmond
he'll make the catch martay tagging up
from second to third
runners at the corners and two away
hit up the middle but there is carpenter
in a flip two to young
2-2 to chisholm is swung out and missed
and
flaherty has his first strike out of the
day one down for john bertie
the 2-2 fastball and he struck him out
there you just have to keep throwing
those fastballs i i mean
when he's good he's around the zone all
day long
and the check swing got him strikes out
the side
and there's another one of those
strikeouts the fourth time he's been set
down on strikes in the series the second
one this afternoon for lopez
payoff pitch from pablo swing and a miss
94
and that's three strikeouts in a row for
lopez
number of gold glove finalist awards he
gets exactly
right that one pops out of the glove
of wallach and up to third goes arenado
two and two to carpenter swinging to
miss 94.
pablo with another strikeout that's four
through four
and you don't have to be perfect with
his stuff
gotta be exactly what i'm talking about
right there just challenge
he's got great stuff he's throwing 96
but yet he's behind
every time and a swing and a miss it was
strikeout number six
for flaherty
1-2 and he gets him to chase wallace
applies the tag to complete the
strikeout number five for pablo and two
away in the sixth
over the plate and down you get a lot of
outs like that
another one two three inning for pablo
lopez he is through six
looking sharp
again a two-two arnado is swinging in a
foul tip walla kang's on for the
strikeout
punch-out number six for pablo is
retired nine in a row
the young hits this one well out to left
but dickerson
has plenty of room for out number two
well you got molina he's got a lot of
big hits over his 18-year big league
career
and molina hits it out to deep left
at the wall gone
yachty strikes in the seventh two
nothing cardinals molina's first of 20
21 and what a time to get it
i mean if you're gonna hit a home run
you got to pull it but wow
he clobbered that ball that went a lot
further than i thought it was going to
go
considering the way the ball has been
traveling there
lopez left the pitch up and yachty
hammered it his first home run of 20-21
and the cardinals now a two-run lead and
lopez pitched
magnificent baseball in this game and
that has hit a long way
he's got to be kicking himself with the
walk to carpenter
and that's hit out to center carlson
back
and makes the catch up against the wall
he's even smiling going back to the
dugout a bit
he can't hit a ball much harder no good
job by dylan opening up and getting back
didn't have to go very far to the wall
but did a nice job
just catch it and hang on to it
again like you got to be kidding me i
think he thought he might have got one
the 2-2 delivery here it comes hit hard
to left field there's a base hit
edmond with a good jump off a second
base he's going to score
and the cardinals lead three to nothing
the stolen base
factors in to the cardinals adding some
insurance
here in the eighth second run batted in
for paul goldschmidt this year
looked like just a two-seamer that
really didn't run too much for him
this is turning into a two out eighth
inning rally for the cardinals the base
hit by edmond stolen base
single by goldschmidt pick up a run
cabrera in the cardinals bullpen the
next pitch is swung on and missed
one two three strikes out wallach and
wallach has struck out
for the third time in this game
and a strikeout here really tries to
come out and establish that hard
fastball
pitching backwards is just blowing guys
away
back to him steps and throws and makes
the play
sends us to the ninth inning pop has
loaded the bases
with two walks and a hit by pitch
swing and a miss and pop
gets his first major league strikeout
and it's a big one
with the bases loaded and nobody out as
dylan carlson stands in the infield
plays in bases loaded 3-2 pitch
carlson a drive right center
grand slammer
dylan carlson unloads
and a long one into right center his
first career grand
slam jordan hicks is
into the ball game here got him to chase
and a strikeout that is unfair
runners had first and second
slicing out to left and tyler o'neill
there with the catch
3-2 by hicks lifted into right racing in
williams a
diving catch to end it what a play
what a catch by williams and the
cardinals have a sweep in miami